[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos so excited to
be joined by the hilarious Gabriel
Iglesias I can't believe this happened
I've never met Gabe this was our first
meeting uh this is our first time in the
same room I've never been in the same
space a lot I don't know why I'm saying
that three ways there's always this
urgency to say things three ways uh no
I'll just say two ways this is the first
time we've ever met and I was so happy
to meet him and sit down with him and
it's a really interesting uh chat and I
hope you enjoy it I am currently on tour
thank you to everybody that came to
Toronto Atlantic City and Boston the
next part of the Pete Holmes where were
we stand up tour will be November 10th
through 12th a full weekend in Chicago
at the Den go to petehomes.com for
tickets of that after that I'll be in
San Francisco Portland Seattle Atlanta
Charlotte and Washington D.C hope some
weirdos can make it out to those shows
always means so much when you guys are
there and thank you to everybody who
came out to the first leg of the tour
this I also have oh yeah almost forgot
November 3rd
going to be doing an incredible
incredible star-studded action-packed
live Largo show in Los Angeles on
November 3rd to benefit Homeboy
Industries go to largo-la.com for
tickets to that I also do a show there
every month but especially November 3rd
if you're in the LA area come to that
show that's going to be a special one
and for an incredible incredible cause
if you missed the father Greg Boyle
episode I highly suggest Circle back and
listen to it it's one of my favorites of
all time and one of my favorite
Charities it's we're it's minimizing to
call it a charity movements of all time
I'm so thrilled with them and this
episode uh with our my new friend Gabe
is brought To Us by our friends at Blue
land the holidays as we all know can
create even more waste than usual but
each year Americans throw away 25 more
trash from Thanksgiving to New Year's
did you know that 25 more trash what if
we told you there was a way to get all
of your holiday shopping done without
out feeling guilty over the waist that
typically comes with it well meat blue
land blue land is on a mission to
eliminate single-use plastic by
Reinventing cleaning Essentials to be
better for you and for the planet and
this holiday season blue land is having
its best sale of the year so you can
save and shop sustainably for your
friends family and even yourself Val and
I as a household we felt terrible about
all of this plastic waste in our house
we gave blue land a try and we are
absolutely hooked it's so good knowing
that we're doing something right for the
planet and also for ourselves the idea
is simple grab one of the beautiful
forever bottles fill it with warm water
waddle fill it with warm water drop it
in the tablet and you get cleaning
refills start at two bucks do you
understand it's a forever bottle instead
of replacing and wasting that plastic
and you drop in warm water and a single
tablet and you get cleaning and the
refills are so cheap start at two
dollars and you don't have to buy a
brand new wasteful plastic bottle every
single time you run out you can even set
up a subscription like we did or buy in
bulk so you never run out of products
you use the most from cleaning sprays to
hand soap to toilet cleaner and laundry
tablets all blue land products are made
with ingredients you can feel good about
try their clean Essentials kit which has
everything you need to get started in
signature scents such as Iris Agave
fresh lemon a personal fave and
Eucalyptus mint Plus for a limited time
and for a limited time their hand soap
is getting a festive upgrade with three
cozy new scents that's apple butter
Maple pumpkin and vanilla chai perfect
for this season I love the scents they
work fantastic and it's just great not
throwing these bottles into a landfill
to decompose over Millennia I it's such
a such a huge thing we can do to help
the planet help yourselves and clean and
smell nice things while you're doing it
so to take advantage of the best sale of
the year you need to go to blueland.com
ymiw you won't want to miss this
bluelam.com
ymiw show your support of the show do
something good for yourselves on the
planet that's blueland.com
ymiw we're also brought To Us by our
friends at perfectly you know I'm
wearing them
sorry that's for the video people if you
could even see my pants I don't know I I
love my perfect jeans I have four or
five pairs of them they're the most
comfortable best looking best fitting uh
pants I own in the world I had to look
for the word pants they are the best
jeans no one needs to know your sneaky
soft secret enter the perfect Jean great
look great fit and super soft and
flexible fabric that looks so good no
one needs to know I got tired of wearing
like yoga pants in public I'm not
staying I'm not Phil Collins I can't
pull it off but why are we trapping
parts of our bodies and restricting them
like they owe us money these are the
best pants I've ever owned I never take
them off I just rotate different pairs
of them honestly and they are made of
Premium stretch fabric two percent
spandex 2.5 rayon for extra comfort and
movement that your man parts required
these jeans stretch so you're not saying
crushed thereby providing the only true
home for your bone and they're so soft
you may even forget you're wearing pants
best of all they're not khakis [__] your
khakis and spare your nuts the perfectly
Gene and the perfectly Gene the perfect
Gene for the Perfectly Imperfect men
just 60 bucks when you use code weirdo
at checkout liberate your lower limbs
with the one and only perfect Gene
whether you're working with lemons or
lentils a three leaf clover or a big old
honk and eggplant the perfect Gene has
you covered take a peek at
www.theperfectgene.nyc that's the
perfect j e a n dot NYC code weirdo for
25 off at checkout and show your support
of this show alright everybody enjoy
Gabriel Iglesias hope to see you in
Chicago next month in the meantime enjoy
that's a that's a big disparity liquid
death or aquapana like one's classy and
one's like did you get that at Burning
Man
uh well I'm thrilled to meet you man
we're just we're going oh very cool so
so turn it on man turn it on Trot out
the specialness
I'm completely joking be comfortable
how's it going that was crazy man we
just got a tour of your house like we
walked through uh people don't know that
we walked through his house to get here
to the yeah Big Comfy Couch my the
deep-seated couch the deep-seated couch
this is a deep-seated couch I feel like
I'm gonna need help to get off of this
couch uh you wouldn't be the first
although you look great oh thank you
people are saying black it's okay I'm
sucking it in the black and the side
couch is eating the ass right now black
sucking couch a lot of mass is gone
right now because it's in the couch you
know a lot of people try to lose weight
just sit on this couch
you are involved but you do look good
thank you have you been is that a thing
no it's I mean you know I've lost 70
pounds during the pandemic but it's more
so just because I couldn't eat out they
closed the restaurants that made me lose
weight but you could order them ah it's
different I gained weight during the pin
all your Postmates it's different well
for me I don't I don't have Postmates I
don't have anything so if I want to
order something I had to actually have
people order it for me and that felt
kind of weird you're not in L.A I am oh
you are no what do you mean you don't
have Postmates you know it's a free I
don't I don't uh I know but I I I'm
weird about putting my info out there so
like like I don't have an Uber account I
don't have a Postmates account I don't
have nothing that you know assistant you
know I guess I could but then it's like
what kind of a fluffy guy are you man
you don't you love food or not you can't
be bothered to text hey order if I'm
gonna go get if I'm gonna go get my food
I'm gonna get in the car I'm gonna go
hit a drive through I'm gonna do it
myself I'd rather I'd rather do that
really yeah
not above uh ordering food but it's
because you don't want your address it
feels weird yeah I'm very weird like you
don't think I could Google your eyes I'm
sure you could
you're protecting something you've
already lost
you could be eating roscoes dude so I
could never get off the couch food
man are you one of them I'm at that
breaking point right now where I can go
either way I can go either way what do
you mean with the weight with oh you it
could tip this way I could tip it this
way I could tip that way I'm right I'm
right in the middle I could still use a
regular scale so that's where I'm at I'm
like okay you know as soon as you got to
use one of those ones with the cars then
you're you're not you're in a different
place I really feel like you're only
you're a couple years older than me I
really feel like you're missing out on
like or look I just moved this isn't our
place anymore we move so now we're in a
place where you can't get Postmates as
much like uh north of the city so I do
get in my car and drive and pick are up
in the hills more or no we're up in uh
Ohio okay so if I want food I get in the
car and I'm actually now I'm gonna argue
the other side I'm with you
it's kind of nice it's better there's
like a just having it show up at your
sometimes you forgot you ordered it they
ring your bell and you're like oh right
and you eat it it's not as there's no
process it just kind of arrives I'm a
bigger fan of going to go get it though
that's my thing why though because it's
an experience it's at least getting a
reason to get in the car grab the dogs
go out just take a little Drive get some
air in the face play the radio yeah yeah
yeah I enjoy driving so if I have to
drive far to go get the food I'm okay
with that too really yeah okay are you
tour are you a tour bus touring comedian
yes uh tour bus and a plane so we fly
out to the bus and then the bus drives
around for four days then we get back on
the plane and come back home while they
drive yeah nice
yeah so when I'm home I love getting
behind the wheel you know I drove coming
here I just no issues yeah yeah I know I
love windshield time especially at night
nighttime driving is my favorite driving
because there's no traffic no one's out
there you could just do your thing
living outside of the of the city has
actually been a blessing to me having
it's about an hour hour and a half to
get home now and people are like how do
you do that and I'm like first of all
it's the one-on-one once you get outside
of the city there's no traffic and then
your mind wanders you can listen to the
radio you have a son uh yes I understand
it's your stepson is that the uh I was
trying to decipher that uh but you you
know what it's like to have a little kid
and I have a little kid so if I'm in the
car and I'm alone that's precious time I
I enjoy precious time I enjoy quiet time
I enjoy just being able to get in my own
thoughts and again either have the radio
on or have it just quiet yeah you know
I'm good with that I like that are you
more obviously on stage first of all I'm
so happy to meet you I told Katie I was
like we're thinking about when we're
going to release episodes and stuff I
was like I'm just convinced this is
going to be a great one like it was just
so nice thank you for the vote of
confidence yeah it's not even pressure
it's already great I'm already enjoying
it but I was like there's no way that's
not going to be great so we're
scheduling the episodes and I was like
that one's gonna be hot this is going to
be great we'll push this one over there
but I knew this was going to be awesome
so thank you for making the time and I
appreciate it the question I have for
you is on stage I see a guy who use the
word bubbly you know what I mean you're
happy you're excited
and then when I hear a guy like me who
likes being in the car with no radio I'm
like maybe do those Peaks need to be
charged by The Valleys of of some
silence some alone time
I think I think alone time is important
like my favorite place to hang out is
actually my bathroom okay I pimped out
my bathroom so that I can just chill in
there it's got the best AC best Wi-Fi I
got a heated toilet oh yeah yeah I don't
mess around my bath my private bathroom
that I have it's it's a toilet with a
bidet two same thing it's a it's like a
Toto it's like it's a total yeah it's
got the remote on it and stuff like that
yeah the best rating changer yes it's
the best raider one yeah and uh I think
we have the same uh ass washer yeah I
think we're getting squirted by the same
Japanese Technologies and you didn't
know if you're like me you didn't know
you wanted a heated toilet seat but now
I go to someone else's house and if I
have to do an away game and I sit down
and I'm like what the [__] is this like
like you get so used to it so fast am I
right you really do and then you
question yourself you're like wow why do
I enjoy this a lot does that mean
anything does that mean anything because
toasted buns because also you can adjust
the pressure of the wash so it's like
you can just like a little sprinkle or
freaking you know fire hose I'm gonna
ask you a very personal question you
ever put it on the low setting and
you're not even done you just kind of
wanted to help you go more yeah yeah
yeah no no I'm glad you went there I was
I don't know each other that way I would
have also accepted like what what kind
of question is that but it's the seal
breaker water on your butt and your butt
is like oh right I do a thing and then
it like shoots poop out yeah yeah I
don't I'm not afraid I'm not afraid if I
get canceled for this worth it to have
people have better more full bowel
movements it's the best and I feel so
clean too like I've never felt this
fresh and clean in my life what would we
do I don't know what I was doing before
what is everyone doing we're not dogs
you ever look at your dog and it poops
and it's always like complete and they
don't even have to wipe yeah why don't
we have that first of all it seals back
up and it's it's yes we should have dogs
unless they eat something that didn't
agree with them and then they got to do
the carpet well then there's like a
string yeah there's something they found
on the street I'm saying I watch my dog
poop all the time and I'm like that
should be us it sort of flies in the
face of a loving God is what I'm saying
it's perfect pellet you know and then
they just walk away from it yes of
course I'm kidding but it's like we all
need to be squirting our butts with
water what hundred percent full stop
paper I heard Oprah say this
Oprah was has a bidet and she was
talking about her show meaning Oprah
doesn't normally talk about poop but
she's like if you had poop on your hand
you wouldn't just wipe it with paper and
be like I'm clean now why are you doing
that with your butt like you'd wash your
hands wash your butt but then again you
know not everyone can afford you know
we're in a good place
everybody's got a hose yeah hang it in
the sink like Melissa McCarthy and
bridesmaids get some H2O on your butt
hoe
[Music]
your face yeah
nothing worse than having a podcast
I'm gonna look at this couch different
or you should be happy that I'm a fellow
butt washer no you're right that's a
nice thing tell me more about your
pimped out bathroom so anyway it's a
pimped out bathroom it's got the toilet
with the you know the the boat wash and
the uh you know it's funny I'm surprised
I don't have a thing that adds soap I
think that's the next level right there
just might as well put a little Dawn in
that engine yeah yeah I thought a little
freaking hole put some Dawn and there's
like hand washers that it's like it just
looks like clear liquid but when it
comes to it's like foam that's what I
want I want like fire retardant foam
shot in my butt crack like fluff not
fluffy fluff like marshmallow fluff in a
in a hot dog bun my butt is the bun the
retardant flame retardant stuff is the
fluff that's what I want and then I want
it to be washed out oh my
yeah okay let's make it let's make a
note of that we gotta step up our game
anyway aside from that I have a urinal
in my bathroom which is like a one of my
things that I've always wanted to have
as a urinal you wanted a urinal I wanted
a journal in my house because it was
just like it's convenient I'm a dude
yeah but it smells uh you know there's
uh there's ways of fixing that a little
Cube or something like that it's it's
you know my ex didn't want you told her
to make a note about my my friend my ex
didn't want it if you did a riff and I
was like make a note we need to step up
our game
I've never been so offended in my life
we're keeping that I'm just trying to
I'm trying to keep up with the Joneses
man uh I've always wanted a urinal just
you know because I like I said I feel
like it's been convenient my my ex
didn't want one because she said our
house is not a truck stop that's fair I
was like all right so once I uh you know
once we were apart uh I said I'm gonna
get me a journal so now I have three
in bathrooms I hope the bathrooms not
just like not just in one area hallway
that's that's really messy that's that's
a guy who can't aim let's just get three
urinals you get a trough like a like a
ballpark yeah no kidding right yeah
here's my you know what the bags of ice
in it sawdust on the floor something
like that yeah
I wanted to where where are you at now
you you had coven you lost a lot of
weight so you had like a pretty fruitful
pandemic pretty fruitful lockdown 2020
yeah I got uh I got covered in Texas I
was in San Antonio uh I was there trying
to do a special I was posted up there
for a month we tried to do the whole
being your covet bubble and uh I still
wound up getting sick I was the only one
and so I had to go home yeah I had to go
home and then wrote it out for uh about
two weeks oh wow that was the that was
it right they said at the time it was
rough because it happened on my birthday
so it's like I turned 45 and I'm
I'm at the house eating cereal I can't
smell oh man you know and then friends
are coming by and they're dropping off
balloons ringing the doorbell and then
leaving what uh that sucks yeah because
it's like they were all afraid of course
like we love you well no we'll take a
chance then come on
come on inside let me cough on you
grandma get in here come on
what cereal were you not able to taste
it's funny I don't even remember the
cereal but I just remember eating a lot
of cereal there was a lot of cereal yeah
well you're not using Postmates nice
like I'm your lawyer thank you these are
billable hours what's I was actually
going to ask you what your favorite
cereal is I don't know why I wrote it
down before you came in I was like I
want to have a good food conversation
with fluffy I honestly couldn't tell you
what my favorite is I just know that
like I eat
um Raisin Bran but it's more so because
I you know
I want to have a better experience on
the Toto with that's the only reason I
mean it's okay it's not it doesn't have
sugar on it or anything but
Kellogg's I don't know what kind it is I
just know that there's brand cereal with
with raisins post probably all right
I'm glad you're here fact checking Post
Yeah because Kellogg is it the the
raisins are almost like white they look
like they walk through like snow to get
to your duster they were dusted they've
been dusted dusted uh so you're just
eating brand cereal you know there's
other ways to get like bran in your diet
well yeah I got a can of Metamucil too
but I mean I'd rather eat the cereal in
the morning or you know whenever but
you're not like a cereal guy no I mean
from time to time no no that's the best
by the way it is that is the best cereal
salad I was ready to if anybody says
leftover milk you got basically horchata
that's what you got is that is there
like a Mexican there's a Mexican uh
drink called horchata which is like rice
water but it's like cinnamon base with
sugar but Cinnamon Toast Crunch milk
yeah tastes like horchata really yeah I
had no idea I was so cultured there you
go
foreign
so but you also had a health scare was
it around covid I think any time you're
overweight you're always going to have a
health scare but I mean more so you know
uh I was every underlying condition so
to have covert that's when you're afraid
yeah because it's like who's covered
coming afterwards yeah it's coming after
people of a certain age certain uh you
know certain health issues already and
so I was already all those so I was I
was very lucky I was gonna say family
members I had lost lots of weight and
was because they didn't want to have
issues and shoes I had a friend of mine
who passed away and he was a big guy and
he had a bunch of underlying health
conditions and unfortunately you know
they took them and didn't they tell you
I read online that someone told you had
two years to live so somebody diabetes
dude that was a few years ago okay that
was I was at my heaviest about 437 437
yeah 437. that's when people used to go
hey man you're a funny comic uh yeah I'm
gonna tell my friends I met you Ralphie
and I'm like Ralphie oh shoot they
thought I was Rafi that's how big I got
really
wow that's incredible uh but you what
was that like having someone say you
have two years to live I mean that's got
to be a story I mean you know what do
doctors know really
I mean it did it did get me to you know
too all right so it wasn't scary your
attitude was like what do doctors know
it's kind of like when someone says to a
smoker hey if you don't stop doing that
you're gonna die you already know right
you know if you're acting a certain way
if your behavior is a certain way you
can't be surprised you can't be like oh
my God right like I know I wasn't
healthy I know I wasn't making the best
choices so it's more so like all right
it's real now let's let's try to that
day is try to reel Us in that did break
I wound up losing 100 pounds after that
but then you know I wound up gaining so
it's like you play that game of up and
down yeah what is it like when did that
start with because I'm a food guy too I
I'm like I was a few years back I eat my
feelings are you gonna eat my feelings
person
I'm gonna eat at the end of the night
kind of guy I eat late I feel like
de-stress my my food intake happens at
night but when it happens it's it's you
know I go for it what is the voice is
the voice I'll give you an example my
voice if I'm gonna like have a binge at
night is you deserve it you're a special
boy it's almost like nice from a good
place it's like nobody can and also it's
from Liberty it's nobody can tell you
what to do but there's also like a
twinge of like
if I'm really in a place like that it
can be from depression of like what's
the point like we might as well just
enjoy ourselves any of that mine is more
so like oh shoot there's a second pizza
you know it's after the show they bring
they bring food and stuff like that and
it's like okay that's why I'm very I'm
nervous about food showing up because
then it's like oh wow it's just there if
it's there you're gonna yeah like for
example last night in the dressing room
man I could just see right now there's a
couple loaves of bread that was uh
goober's peanut butter which is the one
that has peanut butter and the jelly
together oh wow uh regular gif there was
like four pizzas there was Wings there
was mozzarella sticks or there was just
so much food and so usually I'm just
like oh let me try this let me try this
let me try this yeah but you're so I
mean you're one of the top 10 highest
paid why not just buy it you know what I
mean like Oprah like pay and just be
like that [__] doesn't come into the
Green Room
um I guess I could do that but I think
that that's the irresponsible side of me
that's the part of me that's just like
eh you know well that's what I wanted
what is that voice eh it's fun
you know it's I I do feel a sense of
like okay you did like you said you
deserve it come on you were a good boy
yeah you know you went out there you
made all those people happy you should
have your moment right here and it's
hard to come down from that high right
it really is so it's like okay so I'm in
there I'm making myself a peanut butter
and jelly goober sandwich and that's
just like hmm
and they're like oh look there's soda um
oh look there's Klondike Bars mmm yeah
all right sure I'll have a slice of
pizza and then I got my dogs I mean
they're like we want pizza too so of
course it's like it's a little party and
I I think I'm getting the feeling that
it would be too disappointing to the
people that are also in your green room
if you were like we have a Smoothie Bar
because you feel like a host like you I
feel like you take care of people around
you we want everybody to have a good
time everybody winds up in my room at
the end of the night so it's like you
know here we go it's the feast yeah and
food to you is like it's also a social
time you know so it's like when there's
good food and stuff hey you know there's
always it's always um
it's a good show it's good time yeah
right it's you know the camaraderie
everybody's there together so and it's
also a loving thing to do to feed people
oh I feed everybody yeah I'm the king of
feeding people yeah you go on tour with
me you're yeah you're gonna have to see
your doctor you're gonna have to see
your doctor I promise you someone said
going on tour with Gabriel Iglesias can
cure well hunger because there's there's
always food there's oh there's never
been a like oh my God what are we gonna
eat no it's like what are we gonna eat
because there's so many options and was
that your relationship the whole time
like do you have memories like your mom
always I've always been a freaking like
you know I I I'm more social when
there's food present so hey let's go get
a bite to eat that's always the thing
let's go get a bite to eat we'll talk
about stuff we'll eat and who's in a bad
mood if you're if you're eating
something that you like yeah even if
you're dealing with some [__] then it's
you're still you're eating something
that's making you feel good I completely
understand I was actually just talking
to my friend who went through a breakup
a divorce actually and they lost a bunch
of weight and I was like you lost weight
and she's like yeah I'm just not going
out as much because like so much of a
relation relationship is going out to
eat and enjoying food together I was
like I'm exactly the same way talking
about Raisin Bran I had to like
quarantine for a movie or something I
was alone for two weeks I I didn't even
eat that much so much of it is social
but it also feels like and I'm really
not trying to lead you this way for me
it feels like a loving thing if you love
somebody feed them and also feels like a
safe thing feeling safe definitely uh
even if I don't really know uh the
people that well you know because I'm
always there's always random people in
in this business you're meeting new
people all the time and I I just like to
break the ice but I say hey well you
know let's all go eat and I'm always
eating in groups so I'm never it's it's
rare that I'm eating alone yeah and I
imagine you seem like a guy that would
treat everybody it'd be like this is on
me that seems like
right out of the Iglesias Playbook just
watching you stand up yeah I'm like I
feel like again it's that host thing
it's like you want people to be happy
and you seem like a really kind person
and in fact we have a friend in common
Peter Marietta ah you know Peter and I
said which I asked Gabe and he was like
he taught me how to be kind to everyone
that's what he said I was like man I'm
looking for like a [__] in my pants
story
or something you saw a ghost or
something and when he said that I really
wanted you to know that so that that
seems in your personality when we were
doing the show uh one of the things that
I I demanded that we have for the show
is on tape days uh we always needed food
trucks yeah I said I want food trucks
and so whatever it is we just need a
bunch of food trucks there so every
single week we had just you know
everybody out there freaking mowing it
down it was it was a good time that's
great great community and it just put
everybody in a better mood this is the
number one question I really wanted to
ask you I remember reading I was reading
about
um freaking Peter knows everybody I know
and he also said that he said Gabe
thinks I know everybody because he does
he sort of does his name gets brought up
at least once a month somewhere random
yeah yeah hi Peter yeah he'll probably
see this well I actually this isn't as
good a time as any I won't forget to ask
the number one thing I wanted to ask you
but have you ever seen a ghost you seem
like that's funny that you seems like a
type guy the second time is the last
hour so someone has asked me that the
last hour yeah you were there I was
doing press on the way over here no she
was doing some phoners uh and they were
asking me about ghost I've never been
much for for ghosts you don't believe
some people I've chased a few ghosts uh
but that's a different story I uh no I
mean you'll you'll at night I'll hear
creaks and noises and stuff and I'm like
that's got to be a mouse that's got to
be a crow that's gotta be this that's
gotta be that yeah but I've never felt
like
um
what about something you can't explain
you ever see a psychic and they tell you
something and it comes true or they know
something they shouldn't know
um
you know just being Mexican there's
always that Superstition of certain
things that you're you know you grow up
just like oh that's part of it like you
always hear about El Cucuy which is like
Mexican Boogie Manor they're gonna get
you or there's a there's the hand that
comes out from under the bed that grabs
you when you're being bad you know
there's you know
Mexican culture will use those those
evil things as as a form of of parenting
to to make you act right so if you're
acting up you know that thing is going
to get you that's always the scary thing
was that that thing is gonna get were
you told that yeah oh everybody
there's a there's a one about uh La
Llorona which is basically a lady who
drowned her kids
she drowned her kids because I don't
know why she killed her kids but uh she
she drowned her kids and then you know
she would come back and and you know
she'd be like you know wandering the the
lake or something it's just like a scary
story and she'll drown you if you're not
basically you know kind of like that
thing where you think if you look at
that I forgot your name I'm sorry what's
what's the story about the story with
basically it's just you know she comes
back right like
that she comes back and haunts you and
in the mirror oh yeah yeah the mirror
that's the mirror he's in the mirror
yeah that's like a Mexican Candyman so
you're looking in the mirror and then
like you know dude you would see her in
the Hombres
try to translate Candy Man and you're
not no candy man no I know Candy Man
yeah and the bees
yeah yeah scary but as far as uh me
believing in ghosts not not so no
psychics no weirdness uh I mean don't
get me wrong I I think that people give
off a certain energy and I think that if
you're just you know if you keep your
mind open and you realize who you're
talking to and just you know patterns
and stuff like that you can kind of
gauge what what you know what might
happen in the event of yeah but um yeah
no no one's been like oh you're gonna
hit the lotto or you're gonna do this or
you do that or um I see hmm oh yeah I
see more raisin Brown in your feet no
it's nothing like that's what I would
say like that knowing what I know now I
think you're gonna have a good BM after
some raisin bread oh yeah
so I messed up I messed up last night
because on the flight back home from uh
we were in Newark last night last night
yeah man and so on the flight back the
uh I was talking to the flight attendant
and I said hey do you uh you have any
cookies she goes I don't have any
cookies she goes but I have cookie dough
I go what does that mean she goes I can
bake you some cookies right now if you
want
I said sweet so go for it so the next
thing I know the whole plane smells like
cookies and then she you know she starts
bringing and everybody else is sleeping
so I'm the only one that's awake on the
flight so he just starts bringing me
cookies and I freaking kill like a dozen
cookies
and I'm feeling it right now just saying
this wasn't a Southwest flight oh no no
no no oh this is a private flight yeah
this was a private flight that's why
we're you know we finished the show and
then we went to the airport and and flew
back so I'm running on a couple hours I
couldn't sleep on the flight because a
buddy of mine was snoring he was sitting
right across from me like dude was just
cutting the plane in half yeah I I
you're doing wonderful and it's I'm
happy to see you but I can feel that
travel on you yeah this is rough and
we're always going I mean I've been
doing this I mean for you I'm assuming
that it's right for you it's not rough
for me nice yeah the hard part for me is
mornings I'm I'm not a morning person
because usually I'm up super late at
night so on average I wake up around 11
11 30 and then just start my day yeah
that's my number one question is um what
is going on with the touring like why go
so hard
um I think it's because I'm afraid of
what happens if I stop I mean I'm out
I'm always having the conversation of
taking a break but I never do it or or
quitting and then I don't do it who
modeled that for you where did you see
that uh I think that has a lot to do
with my mom
um you know uh it's one of those things
where if you get something good uh if
you got a good job you you take care of
it you work hard and you know you can
sleep later you you take a break later
yeah I'm always afraid of of uh it's
that beach ball analogy we got to keep
that beach ball up in the air because if
you take her off of it's gonna hit the
floor and someone else is going to pick
it up
it's always it's always like someone's
gonna take your job but you don't need
the job you gotta go and you gotta you
know make it but what is the point of
the the job just to play The Other Side
well I love what I do so it's uh you
know that's it's fun I enjoy it I
nothing else I love doing more than than
stand up but you know I'm always afraid
of like okay you work this hard uh
what's gonna happen what do you what do
you do with it and and you're saying it
came from your mom and you were raised
it's always yeah you know would you call
yourself poor I know you lived in
low-income housing but I don't know what
you want to call it I think now that
I've traveled the world I don't think we
were ever poor I just think that we
didn't have everything
um I know I've seen poor I've seen poor
I've seen a guy walk in the street
wearing a polo shirt and that's it yeah
and he's just walking and he didn't even
look unhappy he was just where was that
India yeah I was in India and I'm like
wow okay this is a different level
so um you know we always had a roof over
our head so I can't ever say that you
know but you were American poor America
from first world war first world poor so
we're always having the fridge there was
always uh something to eat yeah in the
fridge uh and I always had clothes on my
back you know I might not have had the
the newest Nikes or I might not have had
the newest Walkman or toys or whatever
but you know I I can't say that we were
ever poor we just didn't have everything
and now you do yes and how are you
finding that it's uh it's cool but I
mean at least I remember what it was
like not to have to want it sounds like
you're holding on to what it's like not
to happen isn't it not stopping like
it's like Jay Leno It's like because
then you get yeah oh yeah yeah JJ's
always working too Jay's always playing
with his cars and Kevin Hart he's gone
every weekend Kevin Hart had the grew up
rough and his par his mom would schedule
him all the time to keep him safe and
I've you know I heard other people be
like I think that's probably why he
won't stop working there's probably
something and they're like that and it's
funny because Kevin Hart I like I I know
I work a lot but Kev I don't I think
there's like 90 Kevin Harts because
they're he does so much it's like he's
got a podcast he's got his own network
he's making freaking and once you think
he's you know that's his latest movie
but then there's a trailer for The
Following one I was like how did you do
two three movies at the same time and
then yeah hosting multiple television
shows I'm just like dude but even though
you love stand up you're 46 46. like
even if you fly private going to Newark
just up in the down a bit I'm 43 and I'm
like this isn't as easy as it used to be
no definitely and even though Stand Up
is fun I mean it does Plateau at a
certain point like you're ringing that
Bell then you just sort of rang it again
like it's sort of hard to get that the
same rush like when we were starting
because you didn't know what was going
to happen exactly we're trying to find
the gig who's going to be there I wonder
how many people are in the audience
right you know I wanna let's see how
this goes now your Green Day
I I remember the the basis for Green Day
said I've been all around the world it
looks like a hockey arena and I was like
so that's there's something going on
there what I'm trying to say is like
it does start to blend and I and I said
that the other night I'm like yeah I go
you have to tell me where I'm at because
every green room looks the same yeah
you're everywhere
what's the name of the mayor you know
they got to put the name of the city on
the floor yeah right by the speaker so
that you know when we walk out they're
like oh yeah that's right right
that does I mean there's no end game to
that there's no like you you don't want
to hang it up or or slow it down so once
I did Dodger Stadium I said you know
what okay what's gonna happen here
because that's like uh no one's done it
and then I did it and it went very well
and now it's going to be a special so
the conversation was maybe this is it
maybe this is the all right leave on a
high note but then it's like okay
if I did that can I do something else
what would that be what would that look
like uh well I was I was saying uh I
said no one's ever done it in space I
got to make friends with Elon or
freaking Bezos to see about going up
there for do quick five
we're just you know because of the way
life travel the world is pretty big you
know there's so many other places and
other venues and you know I just found
out that I'm going to be uh in Europe
coming up uh sometime in the next few
months and I'm gonna play the O2 Arena
which is one of those it was a bucket
list venue because like all right every
time we go to the UK like we've played
smaller rooms and been a lot more you
know careful with the plays but I think
this time I'm like I'm gonna go for it
why not does it satisfy though do when
you do the OT Arena how long does the
hit last or are you just like I did
another I don't know because again it's
like so when I did Madison Square Garden
it was like freaking cool I did you know
the most famous venue in the world and
it's like okay so it was a short high
and then it's like all right what are we
gonna do next right you know and then
it's like all right we did Staples all
right all right we did the Sydney Opera
house but that's that's why it's like so
there's always there's always something
there so I don't know if I gotta find a
new hobby or something else to gravitate
towards it's sort of like if you can do
anything how do you if you can do
everything how do you do anything sort
of thing like having like a quiet
breakfast in Rome by yourself looking at
the sun coming through the trees you
know what's crazy is I can't imagine
that because I I for some reason like I
I I can't imagine being doing anything
by myself
interesting it's the weirdest thing I
know a lot of people that can handle
just functioning day-to-day just being
solo but I always feel like I need
people around me
well people around us tell us who we are
they're I'm treating you like Gabriel
Iglesias right now and if we weren't
here there would be no one to reflect
Gabriel iglesias-ness back to you nice
so you'd start to vanish
but you're something so much more
precious than Gabriel Iglesias you're
you know to use religious language you
could say you're a child of God nobody
can take that away from you or you can
say you're a dignified inherent worthy
member of the Universe I love that yeah
and it has nothing to do with your
accomplishments are you an achiever do
you want to ring the bell so people see
you as a good boy is a valuable thing
wow that is deep
man not as deep as this cow no not as
deep as this couch that was a beautiful
question
I I don't know yeah I'm that way I don't
know I've been doing this for so long it
almost seems like if I wasn't doing this
what exactly would I be doing what's my
purpose because I think we all want to
have a purpose in life and if you feel
like you're doing something that not
only brings joy to yourself but to
others it's like that's that's a gift
that's like why wouldn't you want to
continue that but then there comes a
point when you know mentally it's like
okay well what what where are we taking
this yeah you know when when is it
enough or you know when and when do you
take care of yourself yeah when can we
because I'll tell you something right
now
um I've been go go for 25 years and
when covet hit
covet showed me that you know what time
off is not that bad and that year that I
was off the road my health improved
dramatically of course you know freaking
lost all that weight started working out
started just eating better and and I
felt better and I'm like we were hosting
a green room party that's another thing
too and I was getting eight to ten hours
of sleep per day
and it's like wow so a year of that it
was a drastic difference and I'm like
you know I I think that I've I have been
going hard for a long time and and maybe
you know maybe taking a really
significant break would be better yeah
it's hard they'd say people that work
like in parking garages that work the
night shift and stuff they live like 20
30 shorter lives there's something about
like we're not supposed to be nocturnal
it's one of those things where working
at night isn't isn't necessarily great
that's not to guilt you that's just to
say like yeah you experienced that
during the pandemic your rhythms lined
up with the Earth
went down sun comes up completely
changed yeah that's it I wonder and this
is going to sound like such a serious
question but I'm going to tell you my
answer is yes before I ask you is your
biggest fear that you're worthless
absolutely yeah absolutely yeah
and that's what all the running about is
about
you know trying to trying to keep myself
busy you're not nobody you sold out
Dodger Stadium you're not nobody you're
gonna sell out the 003. nice oh three is
that what it'll be the 03 when I'm done
with it no what is it
what is it called oh the O2 O2 I didn't
even get it because I didn't know what
it was called the O3 yeah you'll take it
to the next level but that's interesting
I'm just saying that to relate we're not
going to figure it out today but at
least you can walk away from this and go
like you're not alone like there's a lot
of us that go like really if we're not
producing we don't know what what's
lovable about us we want to I want to
wow people you know what I mean I'm
always in that in that frame of mind
where it's just like okay you know I I
never want to uh
I guess not necessarily be forgotten but
just be like you know I I don't know
it's it's weird I don't know how to
phrase it right now it's funny I was
thinking about it while I was waiting
for you both to walk up there's a
Buddhist expression which is the cup is
already broken they some Monk says you
know why I'm happy and they say why and
he goes he had a cop he goes I know this
cup is already broken
and there's something beautiful about
that meaning this this I'm already dead
uh you're already dead I'm not this
isn't morbid there's there's a
hopefulness to it we're clean answers
the ghost questions
ah I'm already dead yeah there's a hole
in my back wait a minute he was there
the whole time I I just mean like when
we cling and when we believe that our
identity is in other people's eyes like
we need that
you got it there's a there's a freedom
and just going like this is our this
house is gone how many houses have been
built on this land how many people have
lived have lived and died right here
have you ever watched like go on YouTube
you type in like turn of the century
footage color corrected and speed
corrected and you just watch people
walking around Manhattan like people in
bowler caps dresses and trolleys you go
like each one of these people is worried
each one of these people doesn't know
what happens when you die each one of
these people is worried they offended
somebody they're worried about money
some of them don't know where they're
going to get their next meal some of
them are over fed some of them are
underfed some of them are rich and
they're report they're all gone and if
they could come back and see us doing
the same thing they'd laugh in our face
the cup is already broken and you're
already good like look we're just
sitting here right now
everything's fine everything's good
until I try to get off the couch I'll
yank you off I promise I'll yank you off
but this is the this is the achiever
thing do you remember when that started
when you were a kid like when you first
saw your potential to Razzle Dazzle and
shine I was 10 years old school talent
show really yeah were you the host
please tell me the hose with like a thin
little cane and like a candy store
um I was actually gonna go out on stage
and do a um a routine with a friend of
mine we were gonna do like a Saturday
Night Live sketch and when the curtain
opened up he got scared and he ran out
no and so the lady that was uh putting
on the audition she goes well your
friend left you is there anything you
know how to do by yourself
I said well I can do voices she goes
what do you mean and I just started
doing like impressions of cartoon
characters and stuff and they just
started looking at each other and I was
like okay and they're like okay you're
on Saturday and I'm like what no just
like that so uh I wound up going out on
stage and someone someone says the best
way to break the ice is with a joke I
said well I don't know any jokes and
someone told me a joke and I said it and
I was 10 years old I said why did the
chicken cross the road and then I said
to check out the chicks you know I've
never heard that one it's uh well it's
you know for 10 year old I was pretty
groundbreaking if you're 46 it sounds a
little creepy but
laughs
to check but check you know what to
check out the chicks and so I opened up
with that and then I just started doing
these Impressions and stuff and it just
it went over well do you remember your I
have so many questions you remember your
first impression oh God I was doing like
uh PeeWee Herman Ronald Reagan Yogi Bear
Yogi Bear uh
to get a bunch yeah I was even doing
Bill Cosby crazy right of course
um I used to kill at church with Bill
Cosby
it was just it was just a few and I
wasn't even saying nothing funny it was
just the fact that I was doing the
voices and of course coming out of this
kid out of this adorable kid I mean
you've got so much Charisma everybody's
rooting for you the moment you walk on
stage and then you do voice like great
of course now but I imagine even then
pretty good voices the other question I
was going to ask was do you remember how
that felt did that did that mail
something man that was an incredible
feeling because I didn't I wasn't sure
what the reaction was supposed to be I
just remember I was like a big fan of
Eddie Murphy and I saw his comedy
specials and I was like oh that's cool I
like that he goes up there he he's
telling stories he's doing voices and
it's just it seemed like that I want
yeah and he's Fearless
absolutely and so um when I started
doing stand-up you know when I actually
call myself a stand-up
all I was doing was Impressions and
characters I wasn't really talking about
myself and so that took a few years for
me to get comfortable enough to share
real experiences and stories
and all I did was I just put the sound
effects and the characters and the you
know the Impressions on top of that and
so it turned all of my regular stories
into like whoa right you know what I
mean Secret Sauce so exactly so instead
of saying oh I ran to this girl and she
was crazy it's more so like yeah I ran
to this girl and she's like oh my God
and then you know like whoa I'd bring
the room up right right energy and the
sounds and then the back and forth do
you like Pablo because I I Pablo
actually uh I remember watching Pablo
early on I got to open this one time
yeah yeah definitely
yeah yeah
do something with the knife that's what
I always say yeah here you go do
something with the knife here you go
pull my baby
hold my baby it's actually John Mulaney
and I still say do something with them
do something with each other it's from
what is it what show it's uh Jerry
Springer that they encourage violence
do something with the knife
she's giving the audience knives
Pablo actually uh is one of those guys
that you know I don't think he gets
enough credit he opened up a lot of
doors in Europe like I the reason I
started to play Europe so much is
because Pablo had gone there and he
paved the way there was promoters out
there and they're like we saw Pablo
Francisco and we wanted to bring him out
here to Europe we know he'd do good and
then apparently he was just selling out
left and right and so they're like well
you know this guy can do it well maybe
we can bring other people and so Pablo
was the first one that laid that
groundwork so once I went out there it's
like yeah this is the Pablo run I'm like
well let's do the Pablo run yeah and
also Scandinavian countries yeah that
well like not not the same voice you did
but that's sort of like characters it's
very character driven yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely one of the first guys
that I saw his thing about
um Linkin Park I forget we don't have to
do Pablo bets all day but like I my my
wife and I will just throw it on to
watch it where he's like they talk in
two voices it's like I don't know what
to do here here I am like they have two
modes it kills me every single time so
tell me about from being 10 in a uh
talent show
then the feeling that you got so you
kind of got a hook I got hooked when I
was 10. and then and then the next time
I got a chance to go up on in front of
people was when I was in high school and
I was on the speech team and so every
dad get up in front of the class and
just tell random stories about whatever
but I was getting credit for for being
in front of the class yeah and so that's
where I got my my chops and just my my
you know being comfortable in front of
people anytime every day in front of
class I wanted you to perform that was
always such a happy thing for guys I
hated writing I hated reading and
writing and just uh I just want to go up
there and talk yeah and even now like I
don't nothing is ever on paper nothing
is ever written not nothing's ever typed
out nothing's ever text it's just it's
all up here right I might have bullet
points for things just so I remember but
I cannot sit and write stuff out and try
to perform it like that it has to come
from here for the first time and then if
it goes well I remember and then I
reapply it I I completely agree they say
one side of your brain dictates and the
other side communicates so if you're
reciting something it's the other side
than the communicating and I see you
when you're doing your stand-up you're
communicating the bit you're there
you're talking to them you'll adapt yeah
it doesn't feel like it's a recite you
know okay okay here we go yeah you're
not just telling a joke that you wrote
that's like crafted obviously it's
crafted but you know what I mean like
with an exacto knife like you trim away
the the dot on there and you know what
there's some people that can do it I
just I've never had that ability and
it's not that I can't read or write it's
just that it's it's work for me and if
it's work I don't want to do it it has
to be fun before you had that outlet
and again please know that you're in in
Good Company here I was a really anxious
kid and and to this day if my wife and I
go to dinner and I can't tune out the
people around us I can't just enjoy it
she'll be like you need to do a set and
like I remember it's hard to remember
but like junior high high school what it
felt like before guys like us found a
steady Outlet was it how did that
manifest anxiety I had like health
problems digestive problems like I
needed to find a way to express myself
um you know I I only had a couple of
friends back in high school and
fortunately they're still my friends you
know and really yeah oh wow yeah um two
and I got two so you know it worked out
I chose wisely
um he has chosen I Wesley
I spent most of my time around my mom
and my two friends so I mean it was
I didn't really have moments or times
where I felt like oh what do I need I
mean I had a Nintendo I had a stereo I
had TV cable and then my two friends
and so I I felt like I was always you
know I was always okay don't get me
wrong I had I was always talking about
comedy around them they all they they
all both knew like oh he's always
talking about this like this is
something real yeah
but you felt like you were okay
a kid with two friends and a mom and a
Nintendo right like that's a kid and you
know she's okay and you don't know you
don't know if you don't know that's what
I mean like looking back it's like do
you feel like comedy was helping pull
you out of something for me it did it
did
yeah it did but I mean you know again if
if you don't know that you're not having
the best time or it's you know what's on
the other side of the wall then you know
how can you stress over it yeah
I was bullied bullying I mean didn't
that help I mean when you do talent
shows when you start doing stand-up you
have that identity that confidence that
that that was there for that like you
know the next day everybody's like dude
that was great blah blah blah and
everybody's all of a sudden like you
went from being
unseen to seen by everyone all of a
sudden and that is a rush and a half
right there and it's protecting you I
saw something where you talked about you
love Iron Man and I was like of course
you love Iron Man you built a suit to
protect you
that's what you did
right yeah
I'm crazy right yeah it's a great
metaphor I feel the same way like you go
into the cave like Tony Stark the dark
place place where you're afraid and
vulnerable and you use the scraps you
have oh I have a personality or I can do
voices you weld them together you come
out and no one messes with you anymore
that's awesome I love that no that's
deep I'm like oh
but I mean I I saw you know how many
hours I spent in therapy it didn't have
this kind of breakthrough
this is what we needed was the deep ass
couch and this
counting Iron Man she just wanted my
iron card that's what she wanted here uh
just put it right there time's up that's
good we'll talk next week I just relate
hard to that I I saw that because I saw
your collection of VW buses and your
favorite one is Iron Man yeah yeah which
is pretty and I think I think also too
we uh we gravitate towards superheroes
whenever we have our own insecurities
you're like oh what was their issue what
was their thing well they were wounded
yeah again I'm not trying to break you
down I'm telling you you were someone
who's been broken down to me and I was a
vulnerable kid and just like the more I
the older I get I'm like [__] this is
why I was talking about travel and stuff
I'm sensitive like I go on stage I I'm
with you I'm going for
like a Fearless guy like a guy that's
very comfortable and I can get there and
I love it but like hang out talk to my
wife she'll be like pizza pizza afraid
of leaf blowers you know what I mean
like or like a leaf blower can ruin my
morning because I just like what is that
[__] know it like because it reminds
me of my parents arguing or whatever it
might be like there's a there's a
there's a sweet not just me I think in a
lot of us there's still a vulnerable
little kid that grown grown as us has to
pick up every morning and go you know
what I have you now I'm gonna take care
of you now and and sometimes you build
him a suit
again I don't know what I expect you to
say that no man I think that's awesome I
really do that's like wow okay but all
this couple things now he's caught me
well I did not expect this today
I did not sign up for this ah want to
promote what's the name of the tour is
that what we're promoting oh man we're
good
yeah no dude you're doing us a favor
we're not helping you out you're helping
the show out we appreciate you being
here she's like that's special yeah that
was a special oh the special at Dodger
Stadium yeah that thing what's it going
to be on October 18th on on Netflix all
right okay yeah I mean I'm sure it's
going to be my home page no doubt
pardon the interruption friends now a
word from our sponsor better help I'm so
happy to be working with better help as
you guys know I'm a huge believer in
therapy therapy has changed my life and
we all know the problem of staying in a
place where you're focusing on your
problems and the difficulty you can have
sometimes shifting to a place where you
see Solutions but that is a really
important shift dwelling on our problems
and making the shift to looking for
Solutions and that mindset is super
super important and talk therapy is a
huge part of that it can be tough to
train your brain to stay in problem
solving mode when faced with a challenge
in your life but when you learn how to
find your own solution there is no
better feeling and a therapist can help
you become a better Problem Solver
that's what they do they sort of update
your software in your brain to make you
your own better Problem Solver making it
easier to accomplish your goals no
matter how big or small I personally
started seeing a therapist in my life
when I I was going through a tough
breakup I hadn't yet started the breakup
but I wanted to break up with somebody I
needed to talk it through I needed to
find a way to solve the problems that I
was having and it absolutely was a huge
huge game changer the benefits are
incredible less stress more confidence
and like we're saying better problem
solving so if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option it's convenient accessible
affordable and entirely online get
matched with a therapist after filling
out a brief survey and switch therapists
at any time and when you want to be a
better Problem Solver therapy can get
you there visit
betterhelp.com
weirdo today to get 10 off your first
month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash weirdo for 10 off your
first month and show your support of
this show all right let's get back to it
all right so we've already broken both
of us wide open tell me so 10 to high
school that's a pretty long performance
Gap what was the beginning of stand up
for you because I heard you lost your
house and your car over it is that true
oh shoot okay so April 10 1997 was the
actual start date and at that time I had
a really good job working for a company
called La cellular which eventually
became ATT
um I was selling cell phones back when
they were you know like cell phones not
like these you know tablets that fall
out of your pocket and they break right
like I was selling a phone called a
Motorola pc550 flip phone and it was
literally a brick like you would switch
with batteries yeah the gray one you
would switch out the batteries and back
then man you'd charge it one time and
your phone was good for like three four
days really yeah well I think I'm gonna
say the opposite like no no no no well
because back then you only used your
phone to talk on it you weren't texting
you weren't looking at Google you
weren't doing all kinds of other things
with it was literally just to talk and
then you're done yeah yeah but you could
feel like you know anytime you talk on
it you could feel that radiation so when
you'd hang up your ears buzzing your
face is tingling yes but uh my dad had
one of those that's why I'm really yeah
those those were like phones yeah yeah
and remember the car they had cell
phones like little briefcases
so there was a couple times I would
program back phones people that had the
car you know because usually you'd have
a phone and then you would program the
phone you know put the number and all
the information you had a every single
phone you had to program it yourself
yeah and so I would I would have to go
in and you know do that but every now
and then somebody would bring me a bag
phone or tell me they want to connect
their car phone and then I'd have to go
out to the car and then you know call
all right how do I do this okay here we
go and make it happen but I was making
such good money back then really yes and
I had benefits I never had benefits
before I never had insurance I never had
you know Dental all that stuff and so I
didn't I'm not funny right and I didn't
you know when you're 20 years old you're
indestructible you're like I could care
less about insurance
so I'm fine yeah but it's like when you
get older you're like oh yeah that's
important and so my mom knew from the
get that's a big deal and so the fact
that I had that really good job I was
making you know a lot of money for that
it's a lot of money now if you think
about it yeah
um you know I remember I bought a brand
new leather jacket at Wilson's house of
suede I was all excited my car at an
apartment and then when I quit my job to
pursue comedy
um everybody's like what are you doing
you know I ran out of money quick I ran
out of money so fast I got evicted from
my apartment and then the repo guy was
looking for the car really tell me about
the decision I know you knew you were
funny were you just doing better than
everyone at the open mics like yes tell
me about why it was going very well I
did uh my first television show within
like four months of of me starting wow
it was a TV show called make me laugh on
Comedy Central and
um I did one episode and they said
you're really good you want to do
another one cool so I did a second one
they're like hey we had a falling out
you want to do a third one sure so in
two days time I did three episodes wow
and a TV check was like wow I had not
seen that before yeah and I had three in
a row and I'm like well shoot if I could
just keep this pace up you know I saw
how easy it was and I thought it was
just always gonna be that way right so
you were quitting with confidence I was
quitting with confidence I I still have
the letter that I I faxed over to my
office I faxed it over and I was like
yeah I am going to be in two weeks time
blah blah this will be my last day I'm
pursuing my career as a comedian
I laid it out yeah it's some I got I got
it's got to put it up in your office it
was that's incredible it was and it was
one of those faxes what's it was on the
roll
yeah and so uh yeah I I quit way too
soon
way too soon looking back
through I I wound up uh living on my
sister's couch for a while oh wow yeah
because I refuse to go back to work I
refused I did not want to go backwards
everyone's like dude the job is just
there it's waiting for you and I'm like
but if I go back to that I'm gonna get
comfortable and I'm Not Gonna Wanna
pursue this yes yeah I hear you you know
you wanted to keep the volume uh the
beach ball in the air yes I I loved
being out at night I loved hanging out
with Comics I loved hearing stories I
loved winding up at Denny's at three
o'clock in the morning and then I
dragged my ass back home and then have
to be up at seven to go to this job and
I'm just like falling asleep during the
day and it's just like uh
I totally get that once I made the break
uh from having a straight job or
whatever you want to call it I just was
like it was when I moved to New York I
was living in Chicago okay and I was
working at Bennigan's and then I was
like oh that place was good they had
really good Monte crisco's yeah that's
it yeah and when I moved to New York I
was like obviously we had saved up a
little bit of money and stuff but I was
like I'm not gonna get a job because I
knew if I had a job
look it's people are listening young
stand-ups are listening yeah it's
prudent you can't not everybody can do
that but at that point I was like I'm
going Burlington football fans man so
it's you know and I was on TV within
four months of moving to New York which
was also incredible and that was 500 a
week doing the show called best week
ever and I was like this changed my life
now I'm paying the rent my wife my
ex-wife was a public school teacher but
I was like oh my God I'm making two
thousand dollars a month doing this show
is [__] nuts but I think that had
something to do with the fact that if
you don't have a job and you don't go
out and if if you're not doing a set at
least going and watching sets or hanging
out or trying around that being around
it but I wouldn't have done it I know me
it turns out I have ADHD and it's hard
for me to shift gears and stuff I want
to do one thing I still only want to do
one thing this is the thing I'm doing
today I was excited I am excited I'm
still excited to be talking with you do
this thing
one other I got up I had to write
something then I do this that's it
Petey's brain is done shifting gears I
can't go and also you know weave a
basket I'm done from for the rest of the
day I'm just gonna be a dad that's fine
but uh I I relate to that like I can't
and I'm also I admire the
you know you got your your suede jacket
and then you got your benefits and you
walked away uh I tell people all the
time because it's like you know they say
what's this the biggest secret well the
biggest secret I mean it's very simple
sacrifice what are you willing to give
up you know you got to be willing to
give up being comfortable I was very
comfortable it's 1997. I was making as a
20 year old well let's see uh
I was making about five thousand dollars
a month that's great which making five
thousand dollars a month now is freaking
huge that's right back then are you
kidding me I was freaking middle seven
yeah yeah that's right I was ghetto rich
I was I was making commissions off of
cell phones and it's like are you
kidding me this is awesome yeah that is
incredible and so to give that up to
pursue this because everybody's like
well how much do you get doing stand up
well sometimes it's nothing sometimes
it's five bucks every now and then
someone give me 50. yeah you know and
they're like uh the math doesn't work
out and it trying to explain to people
that it's not a money thing it it
doesn't make sense they're like well uh
okay so how are you gonna survive yeah
what what did your mom say oh my mom was
not happy but she was not happy my mom
was like are you kidding me she's like
you got benefits you're having medical
insurance alone for my mom was like the
biggest thing you don't understand how
important this is and how hard and how
hard it is to get because I didn't just
have a a regular plan I had to I had
people po man you said Dental yeah PPO
dental and I was able to get braces dude
my grill was all jacked up one day
um and then once I quit they took away
the dental and I still had the braces on
so I had to you know I never got the
braces taken off they just stayed in my
mouth until each one started falling off
individually no yeah it was stupid
um so I had braces for about five years
and then did you have like the little
cement you had to just brush real hard
to get that off yeah I just left it I
just left it and then one day going in
they're like wow you really rolled this
out I go yeah see this is why I like
these stories because now you're on your
heated toilet and you got the wires so I
understand and I appreciate things
differently it's like I remember the
cold toilet seat
[Laughter]
so your mom obviously was right in
saying that but one of the things that
Peter told me to ask you about he said I
always love when Gabe talks about his
mom I know you have like a fierce love
and loyalty for your mom did she come
around like when you
were pursuing your dream she was not
um
like um going out of her way to be
supportive but she wasn't trying to she
wasn't trying to talk me out of it
either okay she's like whatever makes
you happy but she could see that you
know like whatever this is he's still
struggling because I was still asking
her to help me like co-sign for cars and
and you know every now and I can borrow
a little bit of money here because I
didn't make enough and so she's like huh
but she knew that I was happy doing it
yeah and once I got to a place where
it's like you know once she was there
for the taping of my first special and
she saw the reaction she saw everything
and she's like wow okay and then the
second one and then just seeing where it
was going and so she got to see a lot of
the success of it and saw me be happy
doing what I love to do so she got it
she still didn't think I was funny
because she the humor's you know she
didn't get the humor
um but in person like when I wasn't on
stage I was always my mom was always
cracking up I always had my mom dying of
laughter
um but on stage it just it didn't make
sense
just a generation yeah it was it was
different but she would invite friends
to my shows and if the friends weren't
laughing she'd go how come you're not
laughing
so she'd check her friends you know like
and then my mom would Heckle me
sometimes because
sometimes I talk about her and then you
know I talk about it show y'all in the
room that's not true oh my gosh [__] mom
can I ask you this it is true right what
you're saying is true yeah it is true
but because when I was talking about
what it was about my mom or saying
something about her she would she'd be
quick to that's what happened if I say
something that's a hundred percent true
my mom always goes that never happened
and I'm like don't you see this is why
I'm talking about it on stage because as
soon as you say it it evaporates the
glass the cup is already broken like
it's gone and I'm like I have to tell
people that you said something insane
but you'll never she'll never admit it
she'll never be like that was me that
was me and she has heckled she heckled
uh who was it she heckled my college
roommate who was giving a toast at my
second wedding my most recent she
hackled him and was like you're ruining
it oh my God wrap it up I was like um
this is a wet it's a wedding give him
the light this isn't Governors you know
yeah she she would have given him the
light so what was your first special
what was that first break how long were
you living with your your sister oh man
I was on my sister's couch for about a
year before I started making enough
money to go halves he's on the rent and
uh with her I want yes I want to say in
2000 was it 2000 2001
I'm guessing I'm I have to go online and
see for myself
um I got on a TV show on Nickelodeon
called all that yeah I remember so I was
on a season of that uh uh and man every
week like those checks I had no idea
that you know I could I could be making
that kind of money and the chicks were
just you know so all these episodes and
they just kept flowing in and I'm like
wow that's interesting I lost a check
what do you mean like physically like I
physically lost a check and then I found
it like six months later I'm like oh my
God I I didn't realize that I did not
catch this because I was just so
overwhelmed where it's like I went from
having no money to all of a sudden you
know here's all these fat checks every
week and I wasn't spending everything I
was being very you know good but I guess
my sister or somebody had put one of the
checks in a in a file cabinet and I
found it I'm like are you kidding me
that's that's and that was like oh my
God that was the best day I remember I
went to the bank like yes
isn't it six months at that point the
show was already over so do we have to
get it reissued after 90 days you know
what here's the thing with that check is
that no
no it was it was still it was still good
it was uh cast I remember it said cast
and crew it was a cast and crew check
and that those are good forever that one
was apparently that's fantastic here's
sort of going sideways here
Nickelodeon I think I even have a
picture of that of the jacket yeah I
love it I just remember cast and crew
and I had the the thing with the film
like a like a projector the way that
yeah yeah of course
it's a it's a you I'm glad you keep
these faxes and these checks you got to
have these uh uh Hallmarks I even have a
my one of my favorite things that I have
is I got a letter from the ice house and
I had submitted a tape to the ice house
to see about you know getting booked and
uh Elaine who was the booker at the time
she had sent me this letter she's like
you know comedy is a very competitive
thing blah blah blah you do show promise
but at this time we don't think that
you're ready for our clubs and stuff
like that and I still have the the
letter at least they were kind of nice
about it was nice it was like it was not
a definite no but you're not ready now
that's but it's it's a you know I still
hurt though it did but uh the manager of
the Providence Rhode Island uh comedy
connection she didn't even look up from
her desk she went come back in six
months and I was like I could have been
like okay she's not saying no she's just
saying I'm not ready yet but I still was
like super depressed after that you
never want to hear no it knows the
hardest thing to hear
um but that's another thing too it's
like how persistent are you yeah if you
really think this is for you it doesn't
matter how many times people tell you no
it's like no I know this is right right
I know that you have to have a certain
level of stubbornness and just like
drive and because if you give up easy or
let people sway you yeah then that's you
know that's your downfall right if you
had a different personality maybe or a
different temperament you might have
quit because you got so many no's but
did you it just felt so right getting
loud it felt so right and like I said
I'm I'm a stubborn person I'm reasonable
and I'm logical if you can show me that
you're you're ways better yeah you know
but still it felt like not to put words
in your mouth but like kind of like a
coming home like this is who I was
always meant to be so if someone gave
you a letter I knew I was meant to be a
comic I just didn't know how I was going
to do it yeah dude I say this on the
show all the time it I bet you'll relate
though I was at an open mic
meaning most people don't relate does
that open mic there were three people
there this is in Chicago and I vividly
remember saying the only time I did the
bid if you can call it a bit was I was
like I know what I'm supposed to sound
like I know my Cadence I just don't know
the words like I know I'm supposed to be
like
and then you'll be like and then I'll be
like I don't know but I was up there
going like RoboCop like I I just hadn't
found it I couldn't wait to be a real
comedian that had opinions and raised my
voice and and acted things out and I
just didn't know but I could see it and
that was my certainty I was like I know
I will do that at some point but right
now I'm standing here Frozen just kind
of like oh yeah you know like I wasn't
that nervous but like you know not good
yet but I could see it but also to
perform for three people that's that's
super stressful oh yeah you know I
remember doing that and just knowing
that like uh the energy is not the same
so I was you know I always base my show
on the energy that I get from the people
so I rely on the feedback so if the
feedback is good I'm Gonna Keep it going
so if it's high energy I'm going to be
high energy yeah but if for some reason
it's like you know the crowds then I'm
going into okay that's right to complete
that game I mirror too yeah and that's
why so many comedians I see they go up
and they're shooting shotguns basically
they're really going hard I'm like
that's not that's not what the crowd is
like you're asking them to do something
that they haven't shown that they can do
and I don't think they can do it like
it's better to like I find it more
powerful if the crowd's real audio quiet
to go up and be quiet like I did The
Improv the other night it was a Sunday
night and for some reason it was just
light and everyone was going like it's
still Saturday okay it's still Saturday
I don't know why I'm Bill Burr all of a
sudden but you know they're going loud
and they're doing bits in fifth gear and
not to say I learned this from watching
other Comics I just did what I learned I
went up and I'm like off mic I'm just
like wait you know I the first thing I
said was don't feel nervous I actually
prefer it like this I like it sleepy be
sleepy and I started like kind of
talking about how quiet the one was but
telling them it's five you don't have to
do it you don't have to be the crowd
people expect you to be I don't have to
be the comic people expect to be like
finding this like and before we knew it
we were off and running but you can't
just go up and act like it's Saturday 10
o'clock Sunday seven o'clock yeah right
um
depending on like I got a chance to go
to the uh Melrose Club
about two months ago um Adam Carolla put
together this this show it was actually
really awesome shows it was Adam Carolla
it was uh Rob Schneider
um Sarah Silverman
who else was on it was like Patton
Oswald uh Jay Moore myself
very nice like woof that's great and uh
oh and Leno Leno was there too well
and it was one of those things where the
energy that room never gives off good
energy like that it's always very unlike
the ice house which always seems to
happen yeah wood floors help I always
tell people wood floors helps
because you get that bounce you get the
echo it's almost like being in the
bathroom that was meltdown the wood
walls that melt down yeah so every
special or CD I remember anytime someone
would record a CD they would always
record it at the ice house because the
Acoustics were so good yep yep you know
and they write nice me nice rejection
letters that's nice there was a lot of
clubs that wouldn't accept ice house uh
oh yeah I heard that because if the room
sounded so good yeah I I actually agree
with them you shouldn't give me a tape
from I don't know you gotta be somewhere
in a hole in the walls exactly here's
the here's the sideways question I had
for you
I've also made it
where I've made it in my career in part
to the fact that I come off even if I'm
saying something dirty people are like I
love that clean comedian like like I
just kind of have a wholesome feel so do
you and when you mention Nickelodeon and
all that and I actually I saw a quote of
yours where you talked about like when
you're starting out like try not to talk
about too many divisive things like just
try to appeal to everybody you'll get
more fans that way right out of my
playbook too when I was starting out I
was like why are you talking about the
Iraq War you don't know what they think
just make them laugh just talk about
things everybody can like now you're in
your 40s
I wonder is there any
when people buy a ticket to your show
it's almost like a theme park like you
want the fluffy experience yes and if
you went out and that's great on one
hand but on the other hand it could be
golden handcuffs like if you wanted to
be like
I want to talk about something real I
want to talk about my separation or I
want to talk about like in a real way I
don't mean in an ugly way like a you
know being gross about it but like you
want to get you know a little bit more
confessional or honest or dirty or
whatever it may be do you ever feel
constrained or tempted to go the other
way that's a shock but just to be
another kind of artist right
um you know for many years it's like yes
you stay in a certain mold you like be
friendly be clean be kind just be make
sure that you know everyone has a good
time a good experience but yeah sharing
stories about you know you have to
evolve because if you continue to do the
exact same thing eventually people are
going to be like yeah I already know
that I already know how it's going to be
yeah so the fact that like now I'm
talking about I'm making it clear
yeah I'm 46 now yeah like I mean I
remember when I used to have hair yeah I
remember this and I remember that and
and telling stories about how things
were back then versus the way things are
and now
um I can
it's all in in the delivery it's all in
the delivery and how you I know what you
mean put it out there the intent
um
there's ways that I can express myself
but I'm very
I'm very creative with the way that I
put it out there so instead of just
being blunt and saying like I don't
agree with this or a flat up you know
I'll share a story and I'll and I'll
like um
for example I'm talking about how
I've maxed out on how far I'm willing to
grow with Society now because I think
it's just ridiculous everything is just
like are you kidding me this is too
sensitive out there it's it's very
uncomfortable I go I'm a comic who's not
divisive but yet I feel pressured I said
every day it's a it's a struggle you
know to try to learn the new things and
what's the new lingo what's the right
way to say things what's going to get
you canceled what is okay and so I'm
sharing a story about how I went to
McDonald's and uh I was buying food for
a homeless family outside and I was
telling the cashier I go hey um you know
can I get some extra napkins and you
guys have the little wet naps she goes
well you can use the restroom if you
want to wash your hands I go no it's for
the homeless family outside I want to
make sure they can clean their hands and
the manager comes over and she's like uh
did you say that you know you were
getting this food for the family outside
I go I hope that's okay she goes yeah
she goes but um you can't say homeless
anymore
I go what
she goes you can't say homeless anymore
the the new pc term is unhoused
I go are you kidding me she's like if
you can't get with that you're part of
the problem not the solution Echo that's
ridiculous
and I got loud and she goes are you she
goes sir lower your voice I go if that's
the case you know what I go from now on
I'm no longer fat I'm unexercised
and she goes that's ridiculous I go no
it's not and I go we can't get with that
you're part of the problem not the
solution and so it was this whole thing
where I'm trying to show my frustration
but at the same time it's like
I was able to convey a message about
something that I feel strongly about now
but it's not coming across abrasive well
I think we I think that's a very
interesting story especially in the
sense that you're showing the preference
you're buying food and and people are
siding with language which I understand
is important over your feeding us your
stomachs you know I mean you and and you
just didn't know so when she said you
can't say homeless anymore I said who
complained
who complained and then because when I
went out there to give the food to the
family you know I asked the lady well
how long you know you you're right how
long have you been here she goes she
goes yeah we've been homeless now for
five days I'm like I don't know if you
know this
I didn't say anything because I'm not a
dick so
oh my God but see being able to share
stuff like that now it's it's that's the
challenge the challenge is how can you
convey your frustrations and your
feelings without yes without rubbing
people the wrong way and still staying
in the vein of what you do yeah and
saying and speaking your Your Truth uh
do you forgive me for not knowing I've
seen so much of your stuff but have you
talked about your separating from your
partner oh yeah yeah that's and then
that's that's in the new special October
18th uh yeah I mentioned I mentioned
that uh you know some of the things I
had to go through and and how you know
what flavor Was it crazy spicy what do
you mean mild the this the split oh no
if it was a salsa
and I'm not saying that because you're
Mexican no but it is just saying
actually no I say I was talking to my
friend Kate who you met on the way and I
was like I'm not saying this because
you're Jewish it's a Mitzvah I was like
I would have said that anyway so really
I like to think of things in Salsas was
it was it like
unstable was it wild the split you know
what I I know a lot of people who've
gone through divorce or breakups and and
you know based on stories I've heard I
can't say that it was like you know it
wasn't pleasant for sure but I can't say
that it was like oh my God right it
wasn't a deer head in your bed no no no
but it was hard not at all it was hard
it was very hard
um yeah I mean the fact that I can still
reach out to her and she checks on me
you know years later that's that that in
itself says that it wasn't as you know
because I have friends that have gone
through some like like dude they keep
really they keep your car right you know
yeah they're still they're still calling
they're still stalking they're you know
maybe you've been doing things to be
vindictive they're doing things to still
just to hurt harm you yeah you know and
that's that's not the case for your [__]
is your [__] and it must have been
difficult who's and by the way obviously
this is your episode so if you don't
want to talk about we don't have to but
who wanted to end it
um well in the it was one of those
things where
it was my idea to end it but then it was
like uh is this really what I should was
is this yeah and then it was a year of
of trying to not end it and then it was
a year of oh I'm gonna make you pay and
wait and so I had to wait what does that
mean basically can we talk about fixing
this
and then not right now
I'm busy oh really I'm trying to go to
school I'm trying to handle this I'm
trying to handle that so delay so she
kept me on a string for for a year of me
trying can we talk can we talk can we
talk is it now a good time is now a good
time and on Wednesday mentally I gave
myself a year I gave myself I'm willing
to freaking
put up with with this for a year and
then I I need I need an answer and then
ultimately at the end I was like no do
you think they were just afraid of it
ending not sure
um it was a great not sure no I'm
serious I'm not sure it's just I don't
know what you know I mean there are a
million things going on but I don't know
what it was ultimately because I think
you know I think at the end it was one
of those like well it's done
uh can I go backwards I don't know
because at that at that point I built up
so much resentment that it's like even
if she was to be like okay now I'm ready
well all right well now now look what
you did right look what look what you
did and then like how are we supposed to
right you know communication is
important and if you're not getting the
communication across then you're gonna
just build up these especially to a
communicator you're stonewalling someone
who wants to talk you want to hear you
want to be heard oh it was so yeah it
was it was rough but it was also going
back to what we were talking about being
Achievers too it's hard to have
something fail I don't think it's a
failure in fact one of the things that
Val says all the time that I love I
forget where she got it forgive me but
she says just because something ends
doesn't mean it was a failure that's
super important to guys like us that
don't want to be seen as worthless that
don't want to be seen exactly so that
might have delayed things too because
it's hard to go like you know what I
can't make this work
and that's a tough thing to admit you
know it's like and you want you want
things to work you want you never want
to be a disappointment being a
disappointment is like the biggest oh
you know that that just
that's that's one of those things where
it's like what can I do to not be that
yeah and unfortunately sometimes it's
just you know was that good though I
again I'm projecting myself on to you to
me I got divorced when I was 28. it was
good to get a [__] in the armor so I
could go like you know what
I'm not just the Golden Boy sure I can
be good I heard you say that on stage
it's like I'm not great I'm not terrible
I'm decent right that's a good
Revelation to take some pressure off of
yourself so having this thing kind of my
glasses already broken bro exactly
you get it that's it you go like this
happens to everybody you and I aren't
better or impervious to these things and
no matter how hard we try sometimes
things just don't go our way was there
part of that to that there's a lot of it
man and then of course you know I was uh
in therapy for the entire time
um I used to drink a lot I'm back to
drinking again but during that during
that whole process during that whole
process of of trying to get through it I
I did not touch any alcohol because I I
did not want over two years I did not
want to make things worse I didn't want
to send an accidental text or make a
phone call that I couldn't come back
from so I figured let me just try to get
through this go through a break
yeah so after everything was you know
settled and you know done then I was
just like all right let's see what
happens and yeah good for you back to
making messes
and that's your your vices oh yeah
that's that's my advice that's my advice
is freaking drinking uh again it's hard
to shut I talked to a friend of mine and
he goes he goes believe it or not though
you're not an alcoholic I go thank you
thank you just because you know because
I drink one maybe once or twice a week
oh really that's not considered an
alcoholic you drink once or twice a week
yeah I mean that's pretty good I watched
the doctor see you just said it that's
pretty good I'm like
well you mean you drink a lot though
yeah you're binge drinking once or twice
a week that's not great if you want I
mean
I I just what a minute ago it was okay
but not no no you don't need me to I'm
not a doctor you don't need me to
validate that I I'm saying I watched a
documentary when I was drinking I
haven't I quit drinking about five or
six years ago and I watched before I did
I watched a documentary on Netflix about
drinking and of course I was watching it
to make myself feel better about my
drinking and they were like if you drink
two or three times a week this is what
your liver looks like something I was
like oh my God like turn it off turn it
off so uh I did better let me put this
to you though as an achiever one of the
things that's tempting or alluring about
alcohol is it doesn't ask anything of
you you know what I mean even your fans
meet you on the street they want a
fluffy moment even me to a certain
extent doing this podcast I'm like okay
let's make some let's make some content
you know so a lot of people are hooking
their you know their valves up to you
and they want something from you and it
when I would have put that right and
when I drank I was like here is a silent
glass of shut the [__] up that that
gives me a good feeling without
requiring anything other from me does
that do you relate to that uh yeah
that's that's that was very nice very
nicely
here's a cup of mine it's just quiet
well nature is the same thing like a
sunset a walk in the woods can also I'm
going to use the word Minister like calm
you down because nature is beautiful
without asking you to do anything for it
you know what I mean so to Achievers
like us nature can be really good but
it's also tempting some of the more
addictive substances that go like I
remember doing a gig
Outside Lands maybe it was it was
outside of
um Seattle I remember I had to drive two
or three hours like east of Seattle into
the gorges and there was a music
festival there and we were going to do
stand-up shows and I was
alone and I was depressed I don't know
if I'd just gone through a breakup it
sucked I I was on the bill early like I
was the first comedian there one of the
reasons I said yes to it was because it
was like Nick Kroll and Amy Schumer and
mullaney and everybody everybody's
coming through but I was there on like
Wednesday those dudes didn't get there
till Friday I was like I'll just stay
I'll just stay and that Thursday with
nothing and I don't even like music
festivals I was in my hotel and I was
like I don't know what I'm gonna do and
then I remembered booze and I went to I
went to a restaurant hey homie exactly
dude it's funny that you said that
because the feeling of remembering
alcohol was exactly like remembering I
did have a friend there like something
that would make me this was and you know
it wasn't my relationship wasn't healthy
but I'm just wondering if that what that
makes you think of you relate to the
idea of something that will finally give
to you instead of all of these people
places and things that want to take from
you
you know it gives until it does take and
then it takes yeah that's the that's the
[__] you gotta find that line where
you're like okay we'll stop right here
that's right
difficult they should sell something
that allows you to measure your like you
know if you drink this much you'll feel
this good but then if you know yes that
line then it's gonna get like this and
then if you have two more then it's
that's right you know that's right like
the the chemistry of it I used to have a
a blood alcohol thing in my car I test
myself if I was ever having wine or
something with dinner just that's when
you need to know like but that's more so
like to get home and so you don't get
arrested and you don't kill anybody on
the road but but you also more so just
what's enough so that you're you're
still you're you feel good because when
you get the buzz you feel good you feel
relaxed but then you keep chasing but
then you're like yeah you start you're
like I don't want this feeling to go
away so then you start drinking more and
then it doesn't hit quick enough and
then you've already had three yep and by
the time you get to that third one that
first one is barely kicking in yes and
so you're drinking faster than the than
the the alcohol is hitting but this is
the beach ball in the air mentality this
is the addict mentality which is like if
I if something is good to me I'm like I
should do it and do a ton of it because
why why wouldn't you and I'm I'm slowly
putting it together I'll give you this
example just in case it means anything
to you I did a gig recently it wasn't
great and then after the show again I
don't drink but I was like maybe I'll
eat like a pint of ice cream or
something you know like you want to
reward yourself because you don't feel
good and then this voice came which I
don't recognize his voice as a new voice
it goes if you eat a pint of ice cream
right now and chicken wings or whatever
it might be not only did they did you
bomb but then they also are hurting your
body you know what I mean like they're
kind of getting you twice like it seemed
like another way to let them beat me so
I was like [__] that and I just went to
bed by trying to mount yeah trying to
cover it up with the uh exactly you know
what's funny a pint of ice cream will
actually hurt me more than tequila will
yeah Dairy oh yeah yeah no I don't know
what we're doing
whoever's watching this you're eating
too much Dairy like I don't care who you
are it's too much
all right
um let's get into the we'll bring it
into a landing okay cool generous it's
your time I appreciate it
um let's talk a little bit about have
you ever almost died
um
like maybe trying to cross the street in
a bus oh and then you're like oh yeah I
mean that's probably the actual closest
where it's like all right I was talking
about that time in New York when I was
filming best week ever my first big
thing I went to a rap party or something
I got so drunk I was doing shots and my
my Chaser I didn't know what a chaser
was was also tequila like I was doing
shots
that's not good
dude I didn't know what I was doing
nobody had ever taught me how to drink
or what it meant to black out and
somebody had to pull me out of the
street
um his name was Tim he was a producer at
best week everybody so think about it I
almost got hit by a car it pulled me out
so that's a fine answer yeah um but as
far as just I mean there there's been
moments where I'm like man I just wish I
would die what do you mean oh because
depression or dealing with whatever the
situation was like oh God just take me
and then you wake up you're like all
right I guess here we go another day
that's something that you dealt with but
a couple times it's not a regular thing
yeah I mean you gotta for me I always
feel like you got to be in a really it's
got to be a really dark place yeah you
know there's been a couple of those but
it's not something where I feel like I
need medication for it or I need to talk
to somebody about it was just like
needing to get through something yeah no
I think every a lot of people watching
relate to that but yeah as far as almost
dying it's hmm I'm glad I'm glad that's
a good sometimes these stories are scary
sometimes they're really funny which is
why I like to ask and I fly a lot too so
I'm always like okay I'll fly a lot I'm
always in the back of a bus so I'm
always having those like uh what if
someone sneezes while they're turning or
what if you know the Pilot's just like
you know what you know [__] that [__]
I'll show her you know and then you just
happen to be on that flight what I find
funny about flying private is you work
so hard to get back on a tiny ass
American Eagle plane remember when you
do it you know what I mean you've worked
so hard you're in the top 10 highest
paying comedians you get to fly in the
tiny ass plains that when I was doing a
gig in like Buffalo the propeller yeah
this Indiana Jones thing
yeah the American Eagle so you get back
on the I the seats are nice and they're
baking you cookies but you're still on
the small ass plane where you feel every
bump and I'm like you know what man I
don't know if this is worth it give me
the big boy and a regular seat give me
like a 737 nice yeah no a first class uh
you know American Airlines or United
flight not bad a live flat very very
yeah very comfortable I don't know if
I'm I think you can say this Ray Romano
only flies in the second one up if he
flies privately
um what do you mean the second one up
the first one is the American Eagle but
the the slightly bigger one like a G5 or
something I don't know the I don't know
planes but like somebody told me that he
prefers for this very reason the less
bumpy one I don't even know if he flies
private anymore but like that's what he
was doing I don't know why I threw that
in in case he gets canceled for flying
see we're so scared I don't want to like
I don't want to draw heat to Ray okay
what about meaning of life do you have I
know that sounds like a joke but we
always talk about some framework of of
the universe and the meaning of life
um a good way in is sometimes do you
think when we die is there an afterlife
do you have any image of God or story oh
man here's here we go so
um
I love astronomy I love astronomy I love
the idea of you know
being able to you know understand the
solar system and the galaxies and just
everything that's out we are freaking
tiny yeah you know like when you really
think about it it's like oh like
literally a speck
yeah not even it's if that yeah and it's
just that like wow you know so as far as
like what's the meaning I don't I don't
know man it's crazy because it's like
you know you see an ant hill let's say
I'm in Fargo North Dakota and I see an
ant hill I'm looking at this ant hill
like wow look at those ants and all they
know is this world right here that
they're building they're building their
little you know the colony they're
they're just working for that that's all
they know you know they have no idea
that a thousand miles away there's
another ant hill just like this yeah
they're doing the exact same thing and I
feel like maybe that's that's us like
we're here this is what we're doing you
know we're trying to get by and clearly
we have our issues and we fight amongst
each other and this person versus that
person everybody's trying to get ahead
but we don't realize maybe that's you
know maybe we're this ant hill yeah and
maybe there's another ant hill that's
right you know mathematically it's it's
too big for there not to be something
yeah so I don't know what happens once
we're gone oh yeah I'm not a very
religious person so I can't say that you
know like a you know X Y or Z but I just
think that mathematically we can't just
be the only ant hill
dude
that was great Katie Hears A lot of
these answers that she we both just look
to each other that's great angel I love
it I won't forget that answer it also
gave me the image like we're a grain of
sand in the ocean or something and we
have the the hubris or the whatever you
want to call it to say we're the only
one like I think it would to say we're
the only ones that's like uh come on
like think about how much energy Just
Energy alone even if it's not a being
the amount of energy that's around us
it's it's insane we talk about that all
the time even if you don't have a God or
a deity there's clearly something that's
yearning to to be cells are dividing and
growing into noses and ears and but
obviously that's biology but everything
wants to be a tree wants to and that
tree wants to find the sunlight you ever
see a tree that's like bending to get in
the light there's a yearning there's a
desire to be and to reproduce and we
take that for granted even food sex all
of this stuff our desire for sunlight
our desire for connection it all goes
back to this like inciting like the fuse
uh the pilot light in your in your oven
that's to me that's what God is is the
original yes to reality so whether or
not you have a symbol for it or what you
go like something's making anthills
man speaking of others man how about
them cookies big shout out to that
flight attendant who made them cookies
last night thank you
plain cookies American Airlines American
Eagle
on the nice American Eagle gutted and
put in some lazy boys to take you on
that tour uh the final question Gabe
thank you again for doing like I said
you're doing us a favor so we'll promote
your tour but you're helping us out and
we appreciate it it's really nice of you
to be here
um
you don't have to think of the time
but can you tell me a time in your life
you laughed so hard you cried
maybe you were a kid
before your friend ran away at the
talent show like like what
I'll give you a few uh guidance here
sometimes somebody fell as it was always
something that was inappropriate to
laugh at any time where I laughed so
hard it hurt was because you weren't
supposed to you weren't supposed to like
you know someone needed medical
attention
you know what I mean it was just it was
like oh my God
you know and I have a twisted sense of
humor I mean I know I'm friendly on
stage but man my my
um
warped and so anything that was like oh
who told the story about the elevator
and he said oh it's Jay pharaoh
Jay Pharoah's Dad they were watching
somebody skateboard those are the ones
that stick out to me he's like he's like
that little dude's gonna gonna fall and
then they were in an elevator and he did
fall and he's like they still laugh
about and he fell in a fountain you fell
in a fountain so you're not alone the
other one that I always think about is
Adam Pally the the kid who fell in my
ankle this poor kid fell in science
class and just screamed my ankles I'm
just telling you you're not the answers
we get often it's yeah people are hurt
it's always it's always something that's
just so you know
um
I remember I was uh I wasn't
Phoenix Arizona I had put together this
mini Comedy Festival at The Improv
they're in Tempe and uh I put everybody
up at the same Hotel everybody you know
I just want everybody hanging out
together and stuff and
um there was this flight of stairs
leading to the you know second floor of
just big nice white stairs and all the
comics we had you know we're trying to
get in the elevator but then we see the
stairs and uh I was there with comedian
lunell I don't know if you know who
Lanell is uh hello Rel I know lero no
not Laurel lunell nice I know he must
hate that what say his name properly no
lunell lunell lunell she oh Lanell
Lanell one name yes I thought it was
like Lil no no no not a little no no
well she's getting a lot of shout out
here what's her Instagram
anyway everybody was there trying to get
in the elevator and I you know we're
standing right there by the stairs and I
just looked at her she looked at me
and then we looked at the stairs and
then we started we started racing up
this there she had a cane and she just
let the cane drop and both of us started
bear crawling up the stairs at our top
speed of whatever it was like three
miles we're both big so just these two
there's two turtles racing up the stairs
people had time to get in the elevator
go up to the top and then wait for us as
we're racing to get to the top and I
just remember when we got to the top we
were both out of breath and then we we
couldn't stop laughing because we both
imagined what we looked like to everyone
of course there's two you know little
mini sofas running up the stairs two
loveseats two love seats I prefer love
and I just everyone around us was
laughing so hard and I knew it was it
looked funny and I just remember
everyone just laughed for like a good
half hour that's fantastic and I
remember we're crying we're laughing and
we're just like
at the end of the day and then everybody
just kept reenacting it and it was just
I remember we laughed so freaking hard
over the fact that the two of us is
fantastic attack those stairs if I'm
directing it you guys are laughing and
the the end credit music starts playing
and we we pan down and we're still
crawling up the stairs no no
holy Polly's trying to get up there no
you're already there I want to go uh
float down and we end on the cane
yeah
and the King just went yep that cane is
still in uh I don't even know why she
has a cane she had no problem using
everything to get up the stairs but yeah
she realized it was a miracle healing is
basically what it was it was funny I
don't even remember who won
I just remember we were laughing we were
laughing so freaking hard you know who
won everyone everyone
who saw that
and us who got to hear it well thank you
so much again we'll look for the special
at Dodgers Stadium on Netflix uh August
April uh October 18th October I gotta go
to the doctor or something I think I'm
dying October 18th and uh would you this
is how we end the show it doesn't really
mean anything we have the guests say the
catchphrase the catchphrase is keep it
crispy it's just our sign off nice all
right people keep it crispy
love it need it
[Music]